over at the aria a restaurant called din
tai fung maybe you've heard of it
it is opening during the pandemic at a
time when some places on this trip are
actually closing their doors
hector mejia live at the aria with
details on this and hopefully getting
his hands on some dumplings hector good
morning
well i sure hope so hey there john good
morning and in the last half hour we
were showing you
how the dough gets made for the
dumplings and now we're about to witness
the dumplings
getting stuffed and joining us live we
have james foo here
who's going to talk to us about the
process good morning to you good morning
everyone uh
so today we'll be going over how to make
our snowmobile process over here
so as we see uh last previously we
make how to make dumplings and rolling
now we're just demonstrating how we do
stuffings and also closing
our trainer here berlin will be
demonstrating how do we do the 18 fold
james what makes these dumplings so
special and the reason why
din tai fung has been so successful and
now opening first location here in las
vegas
that has to depend on uh definitely our
skills and also our secret uh recipes
for our shaman bells that we
enhance all of our pork broth or chicken
broth
within our stuffing so when we steam all
the magic comes out as our soups
there's a lot of magic that's involved
in this it is like the
hand coordinations and also our secret
recipes like those are
how what make us successful now for
those who have never been to den thai
fung what do you typically get when you
come to the restaurant and
place your order so first and the most
we'll recommend everyone twitter portion
lumbaos and also some of our signature
dishes will be our sauteed string beans
pork chop fried rice and braised beef
into the soups and i hear you guys are
already fully booked for almost the
whole week
pretty cool to hear yes that's right
that's we have to thank everyone support
that our followers has been our stronger
support especially during this
tough times of the years and tell us a
little bit about the show kitchen we're
in we have a different sections where as
people arrive
and guests make their way out to the
table they'll be able to witness what
we're seeing
right now yes that's the one of our
signature our trend
for jin typhoons that we do have actual
kitchen every single location
and then we do mostly shaolin balls so
uh
we'll have two table vaccinating for
shaolin bellows and our table will be
doing our chocolate porsche dumplings
our chocolate emperor shalom balls or
krav maga
all right james thank you so much for
having us this early in the morning
we'll be back with more
for now reporting live hector mejia hate
new snap back to you guys
all right hector thank you very much yes
the dim sum quite good the dumplings
everything
quite good so uh it's been a while to
get that restaurant here we go running
in las vegas good to see they're uh
all loaded up and ready to go all booked
up for the whole week
thanks hector